[Music]
let's go to jen
back out in roanoke what's up jen
hi how are you i'm partying how about
you
not so much partying i'm not either i
just lied to you i'm not partying i'm
like sitting at work
like the furthest thing from partying
like i got water in my cup for okay so
what's up
um i have a 21 year old daughter who has
recently attempted suicide twice
and i'm so sorry
yeah it's been rough is she at home
where she is
she is actually in north carolina right
now working at a summer camp because she
didn't want to be home while summer okay
um she's all grown up you know she
doesn't she doesn't need her mom how old
is she
21. okay
is there any history of this at all
um she had a history of cutting when she
was younger
and we did counseling and medication and
things like that and watched her very
carefully and thought that it was under
control okay
apparently when she went away to school
she was about a six hour drive away from
us at college
and apparently she started cutting again
when she got there and we didn't know
okay
she was very good at hiding what she was
going through apparently
okay
um what was the did you ever get a
diagnostic underneath the cutting
because cutting's a relatively benign
behavior unless it's attached to
i get like when somebody says hey my
kid's cutting my heart rate doesn't get
up um i usually want to know more but
this sounds like it was a enough of a
disruption
that
you all sought professional help
was she ever diagnosed with anything
not not that i was told from the
counselor or anything like that it was
just a depressive
anxiety disorder
well that's that's a
she's got a depression
yeah that's it yeah she's got an anxiety
disorder or a
major depressive disorder that's that's
a big deal
um
so what what is what has led to
like what would she say if she was to
articulate it to you when you've talked
to her what would she say um
led to her
attempting to die by suicide twice
uh the first time
uh she did not get into the law school
she wanted to get into okay
and she was having a struggle with her
roommates one of them had been her best
friend and she got a boyfriend and
didn't have time for my daughter anymore
and that whole story okay and she just
was feeling very
lonely and isolated and unhappy
and of course when i talked to her oh
yeah everything's great everything's
great
but it wasn't
and
so that time she cut herself
right down the forearm it's a razor
blade yeah
um i didn't know it was a suicide
attempt at the time i was told that she
felt like she wanted to hurt herself
and went to the hospital
so i didn't know until she came home
that she had even done that who
classified that as a suicide attempt
um
the counselor that saw her after the
second one
okay
i never had any contact with the doctors
or counselors from the first one okay i
i didn't know anything
where she's 21 with hipaa it's hard to
get any information would she not yeah
you can't get any unless she signs it
she wouldn't sign over
no
hmm
that's tough
yeah
that's tough
tough tough stuff
um
so
ask ask me your direct question i don't
want to start answering questions that
you're not asking
um
i'd like to know what we can do as a
family around her to
prevent this from happening again
um
i mean she's taking you out of her life
um
you can
can i ask you a really hard hard
question
yeah
when you look back she's 21 and you look
back in the rear view mirror this is a
really hard question i got two kids okay
so understand my heart
behind while i'm asking this question
yeah um has there been environments in
the home that have contributed to her
feeling untethered
uh her father and i divorced when she
was eight okay
um because of his alcoholism okay
and he wasn't very connected to the kids
and
she told me she did open up one day a
little bit
and said that she and her brother felt
like they were alone during that time
yep
and i tried to
explain to her you know that we were all
going through that and i really was
trying the best that i could yeah
but um
most of the time
when was that she talked to you about
that
uh just a few weeks ago before she left
to go to north carolina okay
um
is it i'm gonna tell you something crazy
that's actually a beautiful moment that
you have okay so i'm gonna walk back
what i just said a minute ago about
nothing
okay okay here's what she desperately
needs to hear and i'm not saying this is
cured like this is curative this isn't
preventative let's take those things off
the table the ramifications here are so
big
that it can be paralyzing
yeah
and the guilt that you feel that you
should fill in the blank is overwhelming
right
oh yeah okay
so you have to what do you do for a
living
i'm a psych nurse
no you're not
i am
and i volunteer as an emt
um
so you know what
you know like before you called me um
okay so
but i was hoping that you had some new
insights i do i do i do i do i do i
promise you as i do
your guilt is going to be
x-fold
the normal person on the street
yeah because you not only think i should
have done some things differently but
you think i should have been the one to
stop this
i should have known that's right i
should have seen it
so here's what you got to do you got to
own that you have to acknowledge it and
you got to set that crap down sister
because that's going to prevent you from
reconnecting moving forward
the path forward is reconnection
okay
so the only thing i'm going to get on to
you about and i'm going to do it like
you and i are sitting on the same side
of the booth eating nachos okay so it's
not me getting onto you like you dummy
it's not like that
i know it's me you gave me a a picture
that i want to push on okay
okay when your daughter comes to you
in a relatively fragile state
and says
we grew up in a wild house
yeah and
growing up in the home of an alcoholic
i mean you know that you know the data
on that it's madness right the the way
that ping pong's through a child's body
and then you add the divorce on top of
that and then you add that existential
question
what is so bad about me that dad chose
that over the bottle over me
yeah
that he chose those other women over me
is this gonna happen to me
like it happened to mom and then let's
be honest there was seasons when you
were just trying to survive and in a
nine-year-old or a fourteen-year-old
they want to know where's mom
yeah or why is mom's door shut again why
is she crying oh crap it must be me we
must have been too loud i must have not
got the right grade right that's not a
fault thing that's the way kids are
wired
okay yeah so when your 21 year old
daughter comes to you and is vulnerable
for the first time
say the words i'm sorry not no i was
there too
okay okay here's what we're going for
connection not being right
the facts do not matter
right
she is trying with all she has to plug
into something that will hold because
nothing in her life has ever held
okay
so here if i'm you i'm this is not um
i'm not giving you some kind of deep
medical advice you know that more than i
do you're a psych nurse for crying out
loud you know way more about that than
me
i'm gonna tell you talking to you just
parent to parent okay and working with
countless college students in this exact
situation if i'm you
i would drive down to north carolina
i would make a trip
and i would say hey
can i have an hour for coffee
and i would start that conversation with
i was wrong the other day when you
called
and i'm sorry
i want nothing more in my life
than to meet and know and love my
daughter
and i spent a lot of years trying to
survive and now i'm going to spend the
rest of my life reconnecting with the
most important
two people on the planet to me
yeah and let's start there
okay
and what we're doing is we're not
looking for
clinical things and you should be
feeling this we're looking for hi how
are you today
i miss
you i've been driving her crazy with
text messages i know you have
i know you have yeah i know you have
here's what i don't like about her
trajectory is um
cutting's not a big deal until it is
right right
and there is um
dr joyner's got some exquisite work on
cutting
dying by suicide is such a
violation of your of a body of a
person's body
that yeah there has to be some sort of
ramp up to it
and so
um
cutting it in for a lack of better terms
can be practicing i'm practicing hurting
and i'm going to push that line i'm
going to push that line i'm going to
push that line and either my dad who is
a swat hostage negotiator so when
someone's going to take their life they
called my dad in
he would often say someone would climb
up on a ledge of a hotel
and be about to jump and he said i knew
within a minute they didn't want to jump
i was worried they were going to fall
off
and that's what we're worried about here
i don't think your daughter wants to die
god i hope not
nothing you've told me suggest that
i think she wants to feel something that
is real
and
yeah
she told me um when she talked to her
dad before she went to north carolina
that he hugged her and that it was the
first time in her life she felt like he
meant it
and that new
set of emotions is unmooring
like it's overwhelming for a body and i
just need to i just need that to stop
for a minute
i can't control that that's new feelings
for me and cutting re-establishes
control
yeah
and cutting realize she'd been doing it
until she had the second attempt she
overdosed and when i went to the
hospital
i found places on her legs where she'd
been doing it again and again and again
yeah
so your daughter is not a problem to fix
at this point
right she has somebody to be with
and as a psych nurse you're gonna have
to turn that down a little bit
and she doesn't need another nurse she
needs her mom
yeah and that's gonna be used doing
things probably different than you've
ever done no defense
no
coming out swinging and by the way
you've been married to an alcoholic
yeah who left your family like you've
been through trauma too
oh yeah but yeah we there's there's a
huge other hole for me we could go down
that's right but listen
very very common my guess is if your
boss calls out a performance issue you
are nuclear
and if your neighbors
call out of something like your lawn is
your nuclear nuclear sound like george w
bush
and
my guess is when your daughter called
something out in the home here's the way
i feel
your body responded before your head did
i tend to lead with angry there you go
and that's it's it's an honest place to
come from and i get that
what would be a great gift
is to tell your daughter
i usually lead with angry and i'm sorry
you need your mama and i'm here
and i know from past counseling that
that's because i have a hard time being
vulnerable and anger is easier yep well
i don't know if it's easier it just
points you in the direction of something
you care about but being vulnerable is
hard if you even get you killed
yeah you did that once you fell in love
with a guy and he left
right yeah yeah
so yeah i mean and not to mention you do
trauma for a living so you sit in other
people's
literally in their blood for a living
like you're in it 24 7. man your poor
brain is just
it's like uh like that game pong back in
the day
right it's like a ping pong it's like a
tennis match going on up there and so
you've got a lot going on in your body
is your daughter under psychiatric care
right now
yes okay
um
i would ask again
um and she might say no and tell her you
don't have to do this
say for your mom's sake i'd love to walk
alongside this with you and if you don't
want me involved in the medical part and
all that kind of stuff i understand
but my promise to you is i'm not gonna
be angry anymore i'm gonna love my baby
girl it would probably help if you wrote
this down and read it
and maybe even practice it in front of a
mirror in front of a friend
but we are doing a control alt delete on
you and your daughter's relationship
moving forward
okay
okay
are you in
i'm in okay college students have a very
uh college students that age group has a
very distorted perception of time
as though if you take a semester off
everything is over
right i can't even count the number of
semesters off i took i used to
convincing students and their parents
just take a semester off go get a job
go see a counselor get your meds leveled
out and then come back to school it's
like super fine when you're 25 you don't
even know this happened
um i worked at law students really close
the end it was end of time i didn't get
into law school x and y and then they
end up at law school z and things are
great
their whole life is different right but
right now in that moment it feels super
real and data and info don't help
what helps is i'm so so sorry
and she only applied to one law school
the one at the college that she's at and
she graduated with her bachelor's a year
early she took on so much
in three years that she got her
bachelor's a year early a very common
response to the child of an alcoholic
is looking in the mirror and saying he
chose this over me
i'll give him something to choose me
about
oh that's so sad it is it's
heartbreaking
i will be so perfect
i will make such straight a's and the
crappy part is if a kid chooses drugs
we've got systems for that if a kid
chooses straight a's
as a defense mechanism
they get praised we just reinforce it
over and over
and then they run up against failure
which ev steve jobs got fired right
everybody fails
yeah but when failure when when that
achievement
is the cheap proxy for love for my dad
and i don't reach
it's devastating
yeah see what i'm saying this wasn't
just not getting into law school this is
dad not loving me all over again
and she mentioned she has a younger half
sister who's eight
and she she mentioned that during the
same conversation that she feels like he
treats her differently than than she was
treated at that age and so you say
you're right i'm so sorry
yeah
and make sure she knows
his alcoholism was a pro it was his
issue not yours
and my goodness he missed out on a
wonderful extraordinary woman
oh he did yeah
but that was his problem not hers
yeah and thank god we're not there yet
i've talked to women who get divorced
from men who are idiots and they go on
the men go on to grow up and get a job
and get stable and they marry somebody
else and there's that rage and anger and
then it eventually turns to
thank god somebody's getting experience
the part of that guy that i loved with a
guy that will actually bathe and go to
work right there will come a moment when
your daughter will look at her
stepsister and say
she's getting full dad which is awesome
i'm glad she's not getting what i got
and she's not going to be there for a
while
right that's okay yeah that's going to
be a long time yeah absolutely
he gave her the same nickname uh he
always called my daughter a little bit
and he's been calling the younger sister
a little bit instead of my daughter and
it's like she's replaced her yeah
and your husband's probably trying to
breathe and he is trying he he has a
hole the size of your daughter and his
heart that he will never be able to fill
up
good
no no no no
i know
i know
but i'm trying to get along with him so
that we can let me tell you this
here's what i want you to do i'm gonna
give you an exercise okay
okay and maybe do it with your daughter
but i want you to do it at home first i
want you to get four or five things that
you're super pissed off about you get
really angry about when you think about
them
okay you probably have a list of 20. i
want you to just get four or five of the
best ones
and i want you to get a piece of masking
tape or duct tape
and i want you to tape them to
actual cinder blocks once you go to home
depot or lowe's or something and get
some cinder blocks
and tape them to them
and then i want you to carry that around
for a while one at a time
just kidding set a timer for 10 minutes
and then when the timer goes off set it
down
and don't pick it back up
and when you set it down your back's
gonna actually ache and your arms will
burn
and so that pain of
that you think that anger is protecting
you it's not it's keeping you from
taking a full breath
i know
set it down and when the burning stops
you will feel light and you'll feel good
right
yeah practice this
being less angry is a skill that you
learn it's not a moral issue just stop
practice it okay i want you to lean into
this
so hear me say about your daughter
she has to be under care of a
psychiatric professional i do not like
the trajectory she's on
okay i think she's in a in a dangerous
trajectory i don't like it
she's putting puzzle pieces together
about dead and about this new little
girl and she's going from cutting to
cutting
where it's a borderline attempt to then
i'm taking pills that is a bad
trajectory and when we're looking at
suicidality we're looking at trajectory
our behavior is escalating and hers are
i don't like the way she's isolating
herself
but she did reach out
she did reach out
she doesn't need a bunch of math facts
from her mom she just needs to know
she's not crazy
she needs to know that she's loved and
she needs to know that she's anchored
into somebody who's working towards
reaching back out
okay
she also probably needs medication she
also needs to be surrounded by
professional care
if she goes back to school somewhere she
needs to be plugged in with all of the
school resources
if at all possible
and at some point hopefully she signs a
release and allows you into those
conversations not for you to go solve it
and to direct traffic for her she's a
grown woman but for you to sit with her
and hold her hand and say hey i think
they need to get there's this resource
available for you or i'll walk alongside
you because this one's gonna be hard
and there's gonna be some trauma healing
there's gonna be some a path to walk
here
but she needs her mom
okay
so let's set down this crap set it down
and let's be about reconnecting
she's lucky to have you
own what was and then be about what
comes next stay on the line i'm gonna
send you a copy of my latest book and i
want you to read it and maybe even pass
it along to her if you find some value
in it okay hang on the line and jen will
get you hooked up